Hey Anthony, what are you working on?
>> Hey, Georgia.
I'm working on web app to share photos
of my travels from around the world.
I call it, Project Compass.
>> That's awesome, how's it coming?
>> Actually, I'm a little stuck.
I worked with a designer and
we made some mock ups but
I don't know how to take these
designs and turn them into code.
>> That's what front end programmers do.
Front end programmers take designs
from designers and use HTML,
CSS and JavaScript to create
full fledged websites.
Let's take a look.
We interact with websites on a daily
basis, and we rely on these websites for
just about everything we do.
But how often do we stop and think
about how these websites are created?
Every image, link, and
interaction on a website
has been intentionally created
by a front end programmer.
Front end developers
solve a lot of problems
that users are faced with every day.
They need to find ways to
optimize website loading speeds.
The Google home page loads quickly
because front end developers have
organized the code in a way
that prioritizes loading speed.
They also think about how websites
will fit on different screen sizes,
which is called responsive design.
Uber's home page is designed so
that the content adopts to
the screen size as it changes.
You can see all the elements and
you can notice the person in the image
is intentionally centered on the page.
They also take design mockups
created by designers and
use them to make websites using HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript.
Front end of helpers at Udacity took
this mockup created by designers and
used HTML, CSS and JavaScript to make
functioning and interactive web sites.
Front end developers also work on
many different types of projects.
They use the jQuery library
to add interactivity and
animation to web pages.
The Spotify Year in Music website
uses JavaScript and jQuery
to create interactions and animations
as users scroll on their website.
Many front end developers also
create video games using JavaScript.
Front end developers can also use
JavaScript to create games like Foxes
and Shotguns, which was made by Florian,
a former Udacity student.
Finally, they make requests to APIs,
such as Yelp and
design how data will be displayed.
Trulia has added a restaurant's feature
using the Yelp API and front end
developers designed how the structure
and data would look to home buyers.
Front end developers work on many
different types of projects and
solve lots of problems.
Let's hear from Kevin,
a front end developer at Udacity.